Guten Tag.
Hallo.
Ihr heißt Mehmet Seller. Ich bin auf dieses Stil von ASAS-Danaastätik.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, könnten Sie mir bitte einfach Bescheid geben.
Erst würde ich gerne Ihren Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Peter Schäfer.
Peter, könnt ihr Sie bitte langsam muschstabieren?
Peter, Paula Emil, Theodor Emil Risch hat.
Mein Name ist Schäfer.
Siegfried Caesar Heinrich A. Umlaut.
Herr Schäfer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 52 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin am 10.08.1969 geboren.
1969.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Schäfer?
Ich bin 1,65 m groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
80 kg ungefähr.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen, Herr Schäfer?
Herr von der Bundes, ich habe seit einer Woche starke Schmerzen in meiner rechten Schulter.
Rechte Schulter?
Eigentlich hat es angefangen seit einem Monat.
Also seit einem Monat habe ich Schmerzen in der rechten Schulter
und seit einer Woche ist es schlimmer geworden.
Können Sie sich die Schmerzen beschreiben, wie stark ich auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 sehr leicht, 10 ist stärker Schmerz in Entschieblich.
Ich würde sagen 7.
Bei 7.
Ich drange die Schmerzen irgendwo hin etwas.
Es strahlt in meinem Arm aus, von meiner Schulter in den Arm.
Rechten Arm.
Und auch oben an meinem oberen Schulterbereich.
Haben Sie Ihre Arm- oder Ihre Händetaufeibgefühl, oder wie am Eisen laufen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass die Schmerzen etwas auslöser hat?
Ein Auslöser.
Da kann sein, damals vor einem Monat, ist mein Freund umgezogen
und dabei habe ich geholfen, die Kartonbeschleppten, beim Umzug geholfen.
Nach dem Helfen hatte ich dann Schmerzen in der rechten Schulter, aber jetzt seit einer Woche ist es schlimmer geworden.
Herr Schäfer, haben Sie Kopfschmerzen?
Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht mehr.
Nicht mehr sind es nur einseitig, nur rechte Arm und rechte Unterarm.
Unterarm und zweitfach nicht, das ist ein Ziehen der Schmerz in meinem Handgelenk.
Ich habe den Kopfschmerz in der Schulter.
Könnten Sie einfach Ihre Schulter bewegen?
Ja, das ist ein Problem, weil ich meine Arm hochhebe, das tut schon weh.
Wenn ich mit der linken Arm hochhebe, dann geht das schon, aber es tut sehr weh.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Schulter gelenk geschwollen sind, oder gerötet?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt, dass es nicht gerötet ist.
Wir haben das auch für normal von außen.
Hatten Sie schon einmal gleich Schmerzen erlebt?
Nicht so wie jetzt.
Wie fühlen Sie sich, wie ihr Kraft die Hände und die Arme?
Wenn ich meinen Arm nicht hochhebe, habe ich gute Kraftgefühle, also kann gut ihre Hände festdrücken.
Aber wenn ich meinen Arm hochhebe, habe ich Schmerzen, da habe ich keine Kraft.
Waren Sie in anderen Arzt?
Nein.
Sie sind erst einmal hier gekommen.
Herr Schäfer, haben Sie noch etwas beschwerten?
Außer meine Schulter beschwerten habe ich keine.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Haben Sie Frust?
Haben Sie Übelkeit?
Nein, ich habe keine Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Wurstschmerzen oder Baupschmerzen?
Nein.
Haben Sie Rückenschmerzen?
Haben Sie auch nichts?
Super.
Ich würde gerne Ihre Krankheitsgeschichte fragen.
Haben Sie chronische Erkrankungen, zum Beispiel Bultwoch-Turuk oder Bultstukerkrankheit?
Nein, ich nehme Medikamente ein wegen meinem Bultwoch-Turk.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Ich nenne es Ram-Epril.
Ram-Epril, wie viel Milligramm?
10 Milligramm.
Und Protakt? Einmal oder?
Einmal.
Morgen.
Seit wann nehmen Sie diese Medikamente?
Seit 2 Jahren.
Noch andere Erkrankungen oder Medikamente?
Nein, ich nehme nur ein Medikament.
Nehmen Sie gegen dieses Beschwerten etwas Medikamente eingenommen oder haben Sie etwas Medikamenten eingenommen?
Ja, ich habe über Profäen eingenommen.
Wie viel Milligramm?
800 Milligramm.
Einmal oder zweimal Protakt?
Manchmal sogar dreimal.
Die letzte Zeit, morgens und abends, und manchmal noch eine dazu.
Bein bis dreimal Protakt.
Hat das Medikament Ihnen helfen?
Ja, das hat mir geholfen. Die Schmerzen sind aber trotzdem da.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, ob Sie schon operiert worden sind?
Ja, in meiner Jugend wurde ich an Blindam operiert.
Ist die Operation komplikation?
Laufen, ja.
Das ist auch ohne Komplikation gewesen.
Herr Schäfer, ich will Ihre Gewöhnheiten und über Ihre Gewöhnheiten etwas fragen.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Allergie ist mir nicht bekannt, aber Unverträglichkeit ist die Klopfernaut.
Wie reagieren Sie gegen die Klopfernaut?
Ich habe mal die Klopfernaut genommen, da hatte ich Bauchschmerzen und Durchfall.
Herr Schäfer, rauchen Sie?
Ja.
Wie viel rauchen Sie pro Tag? Seit wann auch?
Ich würde sagen, 20 Sekretten am Tag, also eine Packung am Tag ungefähr.
Und das wollen Sie, ich bin 30 Jahre her.
30 Jahre?
Trink ich Alpohol?
Gelegentlich trinke ich mal ein Glas Wein zum Essen.
Nehmen Sie bitte die nächste Frage nicht persönlich, Herr Schäfer.
Das ist eine Rheinerutinifrage.
Haben Sie mit Drogenerfahrung?
Sehe ich so aus?
Ja, hach hach oder ...
Nein, nein.
Nein, sowas kenne ich nicht.
Ja, ja, ja.
Gut.
Und Sie sind verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Ich habe zwei Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Die Kinder, ja, sind sie gesund.
Und, Sie leben in der Wohnung, wollen Sie mit Ihrer Familie?
Ja, genau, mit meiner Frau und den zwei Kindern.
Zusammen, okay.
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Schäfer?
Ich bin Elektro-Engineur.
Elektro-Engineur?
Jawohl.
Okay. Herr Schäfer, erleben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Eltern, leider leben die nicht mehr, beide nicht.
Es tut mir leider sehr leid, Herr Schäfer, leider.
Danke.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Geschwister, ich habe eine Schwester.
Schuldigung, wissen Sie, woran Ihre Eltern gestürben sind?
Ja, mein Vater, der hatte einen Herzinfarkt vor zwei Jahren.
Meine Mutter hatte einen Schlaghandfall.
Seit wann?
Vor einem Jahr.
Herr Schäfer, ich habe die alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Und, Sie möchten etwas hinzufügen?
Weil Sie genau gefragt haben, sage ich meine Schwester, die jünger ist, die ist auch gesund.
Ach so, danke.
Sonst, wie geht es denn weiter, Herr Doktor?
Ja, Herr Schäfer, ich kann jetzt nicht alles sagen, weil ich muss die Weiterchirte geben.
Sollte ich Ihnen körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen und Ihre Arme besonders Beweglichkeit schauen,
dann gehen wir die Schritte, damit ich Röntgenaufnahme veranlassen,
dann brauche ich Ihre Blutaufnahme, ich werde Ihre Blut abnehmen, dann spiele ich darüber nochmal.
Sie sind damit einverstanden?
Ja, ein bisschen durcheinander, aber ich bin einfach einverstanden. Hauptsache, Sie helfen mir.
Danke.
Hat jemand Fragen in der Gruppe?
Impfungstatus und welche Impfung gibt es da sehr viele?
Sie sind vollständig geimpft?
Corona bin ich vollständig geimpft und normale Impfungen, die man in den Jugend gemacht hat, habe ich alles damals bis 20 Jahre alt war.
Hat sich Ihre Appatit prädentiert, haben Sie Apotheos genommen, haben Sie Probleme mit Schlafstörungen?
Moment Sie bombardieren, ich bin langsam, Herr Doktor.
Appetit ist normal, Gewicht ist ungefähr gleich geblieben, restlich kann ich mich nicht mehr erinnern, was Sie gesagt haben.
Wussten Sie?
Ich habe die Probleme mit dem Sturrgang oder bei dem Massesatz?
Nein, aber ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie die Schwierigkeiten bei den Sturzstörungen oder durch Schlafstörungen?
Ja, durch Schlafstörungen habe ich manchmal Probleme, weil ich manchmal Schulter schmerzen habe.
Wenn ich auf der rechten Seite lege, mache ich auch, ansonsten habe ich kein Schlafproblem.
Ja, sonst jemand?
Herr Doktor, Sie haben gesagt, wenn Sie wollen, können wir weiter machen?
Ja, gerne.
Nächste Schritt wäre Ihre Vorstellung.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Ja, guten Tag, Herr Doktor Selle.
Ich habe heute einen Patienten aufgenommen, ich würde gerne Ihren Patienten vorstellen, wenn Sie gesagt haben.
Ich gehe mal kurz erstmal Kaffee trinken und dann komme ich.
Ja, gerne.
Ein Moment, bitte.
Ich schenk mal Wasser und dann komme ich gleich wieder.
Ja, dann lassen wir uns mal die Zwischen.
Jetzt bin ich wieder da.
Herr Schäfer ist 52-jähriger Patient, der heute wegen seit einer Woche die rechten Schulter-Schmerzensunskam.
Die Schmerzen seien vor einem Monat aufgetreten, aber die in der eine Woche im Verlauf schlecht geworden.
Wer der Patient hat gesagt, dass die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala bei 7 liegen würden.
Und die Schmerzen stahlen irgendwohin nicht aus und besonders über der...
Ich würde sagen, die Schmerzen seien 7 von 10.
7 von 10.
Ich sage, es ist besser.
Entschuldigung.
Die Schmerzen würden zwischen 7 und 10 liegen.
Nicht zwischen.
Zwischen ist, sondern 7 von 10.
7 von 100 ist eine andere Intensität als 7 von 10.
7 von 10 liegen.
Genau.
Die Frage nach weiterer Beschwerden wurde verneint.
Und die Schmerzen...
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass er vor einem Monat bei Umflug der Freunden geholfen hat.
Und die Schmerzen seien aufgetreten.
Nach dem Erholfen, seien die Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Die Entschuldigung, der Schmerzen oder die Schmerzen oder die Schmerzen
oder die Schmerzen gefüllt wurde, der Patient vermeint.
Und Anvorherkrankungen leiden er Hypertony.
Dagegen nehmen er Ramipril, 10 Milligramm, seit 2 Jahren einmal pro Tag.
Bei Bedarf nehmen sie diese Beschwerden über pro 100 Milligramm, 3 Mal pro Tag bei Bedarf.
Das Medikament hat ihm geholfen.
Er hatte Appendeptom in Jugendlichen.
Er hat leider keine Allergie, aber leider die Klopferneckunverträglichkeiten.
Er rauke seit 30 Jahren 2 Zigaretten pro Tag.
20, eine Packung?
Ja, so lange?
30 Jahre seit 30 Jahren 20 Zigaretten pro Tag.
Ich habe es auch anders gehört.
Er trinkt Gelenkens, gelingt sich Einglas Wein.
Er ist verheiratet, hat 2 Kinder, die beide gesund sind.
Er wohnt mit seiner Familie.
Er arbeitet als Elektroingenieur.
Der Patient hat gesagt, dass sein Vater an Mürkertinfarkt vor 2 Jahren gestorben.
Seine Mutter hat Apoplexie vor einem Jahr gestorben.
Er hat eine Schwester, sie sei gesund.
Er hat Parisien.
Er hat nicht bemerkt.
Wie haben Sie gefragt, kann er seine restliche Schulter bewegen?
Er leidet an der Bewegung sehr stark Schmerzen.
Als Aufgrund der Analyse gehe ich von einer Tendinitis oder Muskelkrankheit aus.
Als die Prenzelldiagnose gehe ich aus der Prenzelldiagnose,
als aufgrund der Analyse, der Prenzelldiagnose,
ZELVIKO, wegen Halswebelsolle, Brachialgie an den Amtsbrachium ausstrahlend.
ZELVIKO, rechts wäre eine Differenzialdiagnose, Überlegung. Was könnte es sein?
Luxation könnte sein.
Ist da Traumabekannt? Nein, aber ich kann mit den Röntgen ausschließen.
Was kann man noch haben zum Beispiel?
Arturgy? Ja, Arturgy, ja.
Arturgy, ja.
Was ist Arturgy? Ja.
Vornaut.
Ja, ich kann Arturgy sein.
Wie nennt man die Arturgy in der Schutter?
Ich kann nicht so schnell.
Oh Mann, oh Mann, oh Mann.
Um Arturgy.
Das wäre eine Differenzialdiagnose. Was könnte es sein?
Ich kann nicht so schnell.
Vorhin haben Sie einen Namen gesagt, Tindinitis, denken Sie.
Da gibt es eine, was sehr viel, nicht sehr viel, aber auch häufig auftritt,
ist, wenn es eine Verkalkung der Szene kommt. Wie würden Sie das nennen?
Eine Verkalkung, zum Beispiel Tindinitis Calcarea.
Der einer bestimmten Szene, meistens.
Die meiste Szene in der Schutter,
welche entzündet sich am meisten, das würden Sie sagen.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen spezieller.
Ja, einer von Kollegen geschrieben, Calc-Schulter.
Ja, aber Tindinitis Calcarea ist Verkalkung der Szene der Schulter.
Das wäre zum Beispiel die Supraspinatus-Szene, die es am meisten.
Also würde heißen Tindinitis Calcarea der Supraspinatus-Szene, zum Beispiel.
Man könnte auch nur eine Tindinitis der Supraspinatus-Szene heißen.
Oder es könnte noch, meistens, wenn sich dort an der Szene sich entzündet,
kann auch eine Bursitis sein.
Bursitis sein.
Kann auch sein. Eine superkromiale Bursitis zum Beispiel.
Könnte auch sein. Meistens hängt das eine mit dem anderen zusammen.
Aber eine wichtige Zephyr-Diagnose, da haben Sie schon gesagt,
das ist die Cerebicobracellgie.
Okay, gut.
Um Ihre Verdachtdiagnose zu erhärten oder auszuschließen,
was würden Sie als nächstes Schrein machen, durchführen?
Ja, so erst würde ich, werde ich körperliche Untersuchung
durchführen, dann werde ich eine Röntgen-2 Ebene die rechten Schulter verrangern.
Ja.
Und wenn ich brauche, MRT durchführen.
MRT, okay, richtig. Vorhin war richtig, nur die reihenfolge würde ich...
Das kann man auch machen, genau.
In den Krankenhäusern macht man selten Ultraschall,
in den Notverlaufnahmen usw. Aber kann man machen, richtig.
Manchmal macht ein Oberarzt durchführen,
eine Ultraschall-Untrosuchung.
Aber Sie haben vorhin gesagt, wegen dem Satzbau,
damit Sie das auswendig lernen, Sie haben gesagt,
ich würde eine, zwei Ebene Schulter rennen,
wir haben das schon in der Geschichte geschrieben, gesagt.
Das heißt, ich würde immer im Kopf behalten,
Röntgen, irgendein Gelenk in zwei Ebenen.
Also erst Röntgen des Begriffs,
ich würde eine Röntgen-Untersuchung der rechten Schulter
in zwei Ebenen durchführen, lassen.
Also die Reihenfolge, immer Röntgen, rechte Schulter in zwei Ebenen,
Röntgen, Sprunggelenk in zwei Ebenen, Röntgen,
oder Röntgen der lenden wirbensäule in zwei ebnen du es fürn lassen
kalopp
herjadab
kullam
190 doğru
190 olsun
notabalm inşallah
okay
Sie haben eine röntgenuntersuchung festgestellt
was würden Sie im röntgen sehen können?
oder sehen können was kann man erkennen?
ja ich erwarte Ihnen gelenk
öden oder
und die
die tendeniz und sie sehen
die surf
nicht
nein nein nein
röntgen ist ein bisschen schwierig
Sie sprechen wahrscheinlich von einem MRT
MRT ja ja MRT kann ich sehen ja
ja aber im röntgen sehen Sie
ist eine knochen, was für eine Aufnahmetechnik ist das?
das sehen Sie am meisten
ja
genau
das heißt, was für Pathologien könnten dort sein?
zum Beispiel, außer dass man einen
normalen Schildergelenk sehen würde
eine Pathologie zum Beispiel bei einer tendeniz-kalkaräer
was würden Sie sehen?
Dislocation oder?
nee
kalkert
würde man sehen
einen kalkert würde man sehen
oder was würde man bei einer Atrose sehen?
Was zeichnen eine Atrose im röntgen?
das ist generell, egal ob Knie, Schulter
Atrose
Gelenkspalt für Schmelerung
und dann als Almasse
Verschmelerung
man würde
sehen
unter dem Knochen, das ist jetzt speziell
Schondralesklerosierung würde man sehen
kalkert
das reicht erst mal
okay
also Sie haben im röntgen jetzt einen kalkert gesehen
Sie haben
wie würde jetzt Ihre Diagnose heißen
wenn Sie jetzt eine kalkert gesehen haben?
keine Ahnung
kalkert, tendeniz-kalkaräer
also von dieser Differenzialdiagnose, was Sie alles erzählt haben
würde dann die Diagnose heißen eine tendeniz-kalkaräer
der Supraspinatus sehen zum Beispiel
wenn man die Lokalisation kennt, die Anatomie
wenn man kann man dann ein bisschen näher beschreiben
okay
Was würden Sie Patienten empfehlen
als Therapie?
aus Therapie empfehle ich
Analgetikung und
keine Bewegung
stabil halten empfehle ich
und vielleicht Bandarien
ja, kann man machen
ja
okay, also Analgesie, was für den Schmerzmittel würden Sie empfehlen?
ja, ich empfehle nicht die Klophenack
er nehme natürlich Ibuprofen
und vielleicht empfehle ich
Kurt Kosteroid Intramuscular oder?
Intra-Altopulär, besser
das kann man noch
beschreiben, also Sie machen eine
antizytherapie-Berichtigung
Therapie, genau, das ist eine
Therapie
genau, und eine Physiotherapie, richtig
damit die Gelenkbeweglichkeit wieder hergestellt wird
trainiert wird
okay
Was würden Sie sonst machen?
bei Entzündung kann man
in der Regel immer was machen
wenn ein, da versteht man das besser
wenn ein Finger rot wird, warm wird
Was kann man machen?
wenn ich Entzündung
bestätige Antibiotik umnehme oder?
nein
genau, das haben Sie ja gegeben
im Profil ist das
oder Kurtison
wäre das
und das andere ist ganz einfach Kühlung
wenn ich eine Entzündung habe
kühle ich das
kühlung
kühlung, Schonung
das ist so Standardwort
Schonen, Kühlung
kühlung, Schonung und
NSAR oder
Studiative Therapie, genau
Krankengemastik
das wären so die Basistherapie
man kann noch andere Sachen machen
wie zum Beispiel Akupunktur
man kann
Stoßelentherapie empfehlen und so weiter
aber falls es nicht zu einer
Beschwerde-Linderung kommt
dann würden Sie
etwas für eine Aufnahme durchführen lassen?
ja, Operativettherapie
ja, ne erst mal Diagnostik
wir haben ja vorhin nur ein Röntgen durchgeführt
falls es nicht bezerviert
wir haben erst mal Röntgen durchgeführt
wir haben Therapie-Empfohlung
ja, wenn es nicht bezerviert kommt
zwei, drei Wochen wieder oder eine Woche später
und sagt dann, Herr Doktor hat mir gar nicht geholfen
ja, empfehle ich MRT oder
genau, richtig
ein MRT fahren lassen
und dort bestätigt sich ihre Diagnose
und das
das EDM und so weiter im Bereich der Sehneansatz
ok, so, was kann man
noch empfehlen, eine Therapie als Therapie?
das, was Sie vorhin gesagt haben
eine operative Therapie kann man empfehlen
genau
ok, also generell kann man immer empfehlen
bei allen Situationen
immer eine konservative Therapie-Maßnahmen
und eine operative Phasma-Name
in diesem Moment, bei dem Patienten würde ich erst immer
eine konservative Therapie erst bevorzugen
als eine operative Therapie
wenn einer mit einem Bruch kommt
kann man auch konservativ Therapien und operativ Therapien
bei einer dissoziierten Fraktur empfehle ich erst
nicht erst, sondern die operative Therapie
aber wenn der Patient nicht will
sie können ja nicht gegen seinen Willen entscheiden
sie können empfehlen
und dann kann man sagen, ok, was ist dann die konservative Therapie?
ruhig stellen
aber dann muss man aufklären, dass der Bruch
nicht richtig heilt, weil eine Dislocation da steht
oder eine Luxationsstellung ist dann luxiert
das muss man reponieren, zum Beispiel
aber generell kann man sagen, will ich es damit sagen
man kann immer sagen, es gibt zwei Möglichkeiten
es gibt die operative und die konservative Möglichkeit
egal ob Einscheinung vorgefahren ist oder
und eigentlich bei vielen Sachen würde man immer
konservative Therapie empfehlen
nur bei OP-Indikationen je nach, was daraus kommt
kann man eine operative Therapie auch empfehlen
weil es diskussive Sachen
diskussive Dislocationen von Brüchen
würde ich über eine Operation empfehlen
also, was ich sagen will, noch mal wieder als Ernährung
es gibt über zwei Wege, konservativ operativ
und ok, gut
das war ok
die Brüchenkacinge Schenes
ich finde es nicht, vor allem habe ich
ah, ok
wann ist Ihre Prüfung?
am 24. Januar
noch 13 Tage
13 Tage
es gibt ein deutsches Sprichwort
Übung macht den Meister
auch so
kein Problem
aber
es gibt eine Wirklichkeit, aber vielleicht
es gibt eine Gütschützlichkeit
dort haben Sie Kraftschwäche
wenn Sie eine Flasche hochheben können
Sie können sie hochheben
zwei Teile, die hier daraus zu bemerken
ich kann sie nicht aufhören, das kann Parisi nicht sein
ich kann sie von der Arme aufhören
wenn jemand wegen Schmerzen den Arm nicht hochheben kann
ist das nicht eine Parisi
wenn er sagt, ich habe keine Schmerzen
es kann eine sein, aber
meistens wenn er sagt, ich habe keine Kraft hochheben
aber ich habe keine Schmerzen, nicht Schmerzbedingt
sondern ich habe kein Kraftgefühl oder weniger Kraft
kann eine Parisi sein
ich kann das nicht sagen
ich bin im Autorik, ich habe keine Schmerzen
ich habe keine Schmerzen
ich habe meine Hand fest anhalten
Kraftverlust
ich würde jetzt weitere Fragen stellen
bezüglich ihrer Krankheitsvorgeschichte
oder ihrer chronischen Erkrankungen
und als er da damit
allgemeine Anamnese oder Nämle
der wir hier sind, oder der wir hier sind
eine andere Nämle
ich habe Schulter
haben Sie Schulter
haben Sie Schultergelenkschmerzen
Bewegungsteinschreckung
ich würde jetzt gerne Anamnese noch
weiter Anamnese, bla bla bla
und wie ist es mit Ihrer
haben Sie kribbelgefühle
dann karıştırmisch
aber ich kann das sagen
ich wollte noch für die spezielle Anamnese
noch etwas zufüllen, eine Frage zu finden
haben Sie kribbelgefühle
die erbauten Dinge sagen
das muss ich sagen, weil sie erbauten
aber wenn Sie sie nicht kribbelen, dann wird es mehr zufrieden
das ist das, was ich sage
dann auch die Standard
die Standard
die Autofotopädchen
wenn es eine Repinfektur gibt
das haben Sie kribbelgefühle
für die Jake
hat die Autos
die standard TOM
aber ich möchte
4 o Artemuta
4 o
Ja, problemlos. Aber demnächst du es dir nicht zu schätzen. Als Ergänzender könnte man noch eine MRT durchführen lassen.
Okay, wieder Örtgen, wieder Therapie, der ist immer, es gibt konservative und operative Therapie-Möglichkeiten, wobei bei ihnen, bei den Patienten,
mit der Fraktur würde man bei distrozierten Fraktur eine Operation empfehlen. Eine konservative Therapie würde eine Fehlheilung des Bruches hervorrufen und damit verbunden mit einer Bewegungseinschränkung und Schmerzen bei Bewegungen,
auch nach der Bruchheilung, bei einer distrozierten, wenn er konservativ bleiben, Therapie annehmen würde der Patient.
In dem Fall war es dann so, dass ich eine konservative Therapie einleiten würde und wenn diese Maßnahme nicht zum Ziel führen würde, würde ich eine operative Therapie empfehlen.